[Music]
fart doesn't tear you apart but I wish
that sir
I guess my name is grace Helbig if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now it is Friday here on the
upgrades channel it's time to comment
your comments let's proceed I was going
to say do it but that seems sexual it
don't like lingering sexual tension with
my audience
let's sit over on point o ever heard of
it the second key short you bring super
super super luigi on the way new person
comes over my social media platforms and
grace the crap of them welcomes its
grace family how do I notice a new
person I don't know I just guess
everyone is new oh this looks like I
literally took a picnic tablecloth and
made it into a shirt eat your monkey pee
long I hope that you're so hydrated that
you P&P for a long as your urine into
this color this wolf welcome to the club
dehydrated ass my friend is working at a
daycare of this summer she used this
amazing image to describe it a great
silver Oh fun your friend has a bad
summer job too this is me and I have no
recollection of what this is from did I
get kidnapped for a period of time then
I'm not recalling it i vlog it does have
a great quick day am i in a closet am i
opening a door is there a slow-mo bullet
coming near my face I don't understand
I'm in a wooden shower which sounds a
terrible sexual position I don't know
what's happening here
but I'm glad I can be a tool for your
friend to express her emotions ranky max
on x nibiru birth newborn Frankie Matt
on X more like Frankie's Neil on P your
yoga directly into
piss puddle that Keelung shorty shorts
left you look good you made it into a
lily allen suite gone big yourself up
well a couple of things come on pick
yourself up that sounds like I'm man
with penis here let me go masturbate but
I believe that it's something about like
give yourself some credit
cool second of all yeah Lily Allen
tweeted what if the Russians killed all
the famous a--'s that died in 2016 to
distract us from hacks and use the gist
of me looking confused
[Music]
someone just those last couple seconds
there's another tip that she could add
to her library to use that's a great I
think Lily Allen's really cool kim Barbu
new pursue forces are making Barbuto
more like Kim booth
rough day for great you're moving in the
comment section of a great stomach video
is an experience no [ __ ] and I love it
now put it in sweet River rid of it
dee Stewart was your favorite vitamin
super super easy Stewart one two three
four five more like Steve Stewart one
two three four or five of the other five
guests at this party think that you are
in the group are those like your only
friends because it looks like it well at
least my friends are more bubbly than
yours yes they are my only friend Conor
McGregor vs. and Conor maternal more
like you sound like a [ __ ] boy or an
Irish McDonald's breakfast sandwich two
things people make the mistakes of
hanging out with other beverage crews I
most definitely do not want to do this
you know being in the digital space for
so long a lot of people asked how I
would describe my audience base and
I always say reluctant irritated
agitated blonde cute
the thing is 2007 to the first person
bazinga 2007 more like Jim Parsons 2017
cat married he got married in 2017 it
was beautiful
I the photos XO I was not invited no no
no you are the person meant for me to be
physically in its presence first it's
not like the wedding near the room she
looks better than I do on a normal basis
amazing
are you would note that learned how to
type as if to personify a very specific
vocal cadence and you're a fan of Big
Bang Theory Wow note you got culture you
got class
you got style you've got your ass Kelly
hang up my princess super super super
geek references more like same present
yes usually how it goes
never bruised it was just the most
judgmental eyes I've ever seen on a dog
well let's see what she thinks
Oh
Judith came her five if I'm super super
you Hannah timber five more like a night
a mere five fingers in class I'm
masturbating openly in class you look
good Alan G with a digital your dog cry
face emoji cry face emoji by the way she
looks so good um I just loved her and
took care of her and nurtured her and
then that's dressed up her a nice boy
determine my own social media game awful
justice automatic another a good teacher
on her still meant exploited it but not
around
[Music]
social media Cana no good of you've
never heard of it as being a busy person
for you as being more like ass but Apps
is a but but are all but asses you have
a root in the six years I've been
watching you do things on the internet
I've seen you do some really dumb things
but this may be the dumbest thing of all
this is the pinnacle of your dumbness
don't change I love it these don't tell
me I'm speaking my dumb right now
because I can get dumber you guys don't
challenge me to get Dumber because I can
get Dumber I will get Dumber I will dumb
down don't you dare tell me I've outdone
myself because I will dumb it hard I
will I will be so dumb subscribe to my
youtube channel awesome
abnormality new believer Snickers an
awesome abnormality more like awesome
ABS Norm Macdonald is a phrase I will
probably never say outside of this room
the other group ladies mother could 100%
be one of those classic Swedish British
people tall and beautiful and dressed Oh
goddamn charming this is a very specific
category for my mother to be in are
there other those green Aloia an uber
uber Snickers and Karina Loya more like
turning a lawyer and finish to use a
lawyer up and Sue you for being so
engaged with my content I'm not going to
see you I'm gonna applaud you you're the
group I watched this last night very
drunk and I for some reason thought I
was watching this on a CD and that it
was scratched every time those
repetitive edits played I literally
paused the video took the CD out i was
watching blaze of glory law cleaned it I
forgot to put it back in without
realizing when the edits happen again I
got really frustrated and was confused
when I tried to take the CD out and it
wasn't there I woke up with it stuck to
my shoulder I'm only a little
embarrassed Green oh wow no one should
have to live like the way you've been
living thank you for telling your story
you're very brave
and I hope you inspire a lot of other
people out there that might be dealing
with the same thing because no one
should live like this no one should own
blaze of glory on a CT okay that's never
coming together coming this week thank
you guys so much for commenting across
on our social media platforms if you
don't know already I'm at grace Helbig
across the board give this video a
thumbs up if you like these types of
videos and subscribe to this YouTube
channel because it's the great Qin mo
says someone out there unrelated to me
by blood and make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes of them
that I don't realize papi super super
Snooper and Bri lo stuffies more like
Keith loves puppies but do probably some
cheese no not good for that oh my brain
broke in that one I feel like grace is
finally lost it oh no I found it